this morning president Trump is calling
for a change to our nation's gun laws in
a pair of tweets he wrote quote
Republicans and Democrats must come
together and get strong background
checks the president's words come after
back-to-back mass shootings over the
weekend in the first twenty people were
killed and 26 others hurt at a Walmart
in El Paso Texas then 13 hours later a
gunman opened fire and killed nine
people in Dayton Ohio in both attacks
the shooters used assault style rifles
prosecutors in El Paso are treating the
case as domestic terrorism they are
seeking the death penalty for the
suspect 21 year old Patrick Cruces he
allegedly posted a racist manifesto
online just before the shooting
denouncing the growing Hispanic
population in Texas
[Music]
I actually started trying to run but I
realized my cousin wasn't one side of me
when I look back it's how I was able to
see that people are actually less of
guns in Walmart
it's my gosh chilling video from the
scene there CBS Evening News anchor and
managing editor Norah O'Donnell is in El
Paso along with the city's mayor Norah
good morning and good morning to you
that's right I'm here with El Paso Mayor
D Margo and mayor thank you and I am so
sorry for your community's loss thank
you is the President of the United
States going to come visit El Paso Texas
I don't know I haven't had anything
confirmed I've heard rumors of that but
I have I don't know did you speak with
President Trump he called me yesterday
afternoon offered his condolences was
very gracious in his call wanted to know
if there was anything we needed we did
declare a disaster emergency yesterday
so we were eligible for state funds to
support what we need I pulled him at
this juncture I didn't know of anything
and but he did but that I would we would
be sure to let him know you've clashed
with the president in the past on some
issues the president will address the
nation this morning what do you think he
can say to help heal I don't know I
obviously don't know I'm not sure there
are words out there right now - given
what we've gone through and what Dayton
has been going through
I wish I know let me ask you we're
beginning to learn more about the
victims 20 dead inside that Walmart
right there has the coroner been able to
notify all the families it's my
understanding it of yesterday afternoon
all of the victims have been identified
and their families have been notified
and the victims have been sent to the
mortuary
but we've caught Topsy and then they'll
be released for funeral and that was a
critical component to start the
beginning of closure right you pushed
for that you wanted to make sure these
families could know right away well I
had the governor was here Saturday and
we had we visited Saturday evening and
he said one of the things that he has
learned and it's unfortunate that he
said the experience he has with the
southern shooting and the Santa Fe
school shooting last year he said one of
the most critical things is to get that
process and get the family started on
the road to closure so I pushed our
Police Department achieves to get this
the investigation wrapped up as quickly
as they could without jeopardizing me
any evidence or otherwise and get them
get the families notified
what do you want people to know about
this community this city of El Paso El
Paso is a unique community this
individual this hate-filled
person deranged came from another part
of came from outside of El Paso I am
firmly convinced it that this would have
never occurred with an El pass one we're
a community that has a history dating
back 350 years as a region a hundred
years before the United States was even
formed we're
we're binational bicultural bilingual
region of two and a half million people
and our average age is 32 people don't
understand where we are we are totally
unique for North America and on a border
with Mexico well we're wishing everybody
well and thank you mayor marvel we
appreciate it thank you all right I'm
gonna send it back to you in New York
for more coverage of these weekend's
mass shootings all right Thank You Nora